Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Welcome to episode 600! And today you will see
your own rough drawings come to life as beautiful
photorealistic images. And it turns out, you can
try it too. I’ll tell you about it in a moment.
This technique is called GauGAN2, and yes, this
is really happening. In goes a rough drawing,
and out comes an image of this quality. That
is incredible. But here, there is something
that is even more incredible. What is it? Well,
drawing is an iterative process. But, once we are
committed to an idea, we need to refine it over
and over, which takes quite a bit of time, and
let’s be honest here, sometimes, things come out
differently than we may have imagined. But this,
this is different. Here, you can change things
as quickly as you can think of the change. You
can even request a bunch of variations on
the same theme, and get them right away.
But that’s not all, not even close. Get this, with
this, you can draw, even without drawing. Yes,
really. How is that even possible?
Well, if we don’t feel like drawing,
we can just type what we wish to see,
and…my goodness, it not only generates
these images according to the written description,
but this description can get pretty elaborate.
For instance, we can get ocean waves, that’s
great, but now, let’s add some rocks…and
a beach too. And there we go!
We can also use an image as a starting point,
then, just delete the undesirable parts,
and have it inpainted by the algorithm. Now,
okay this is nothing new, computer graphics
researchers were able to do this for more
than 10 years now. But hold on to your papers,
because they couldn’t do this. We can fill
in these gaps with a written description.
Couldn’t witness the northern lights
in person? No worries, here you go.
And, wait a second…did you see that? There
are two cool really cool things to see here.
Thing number one, it even redraws
the reflections on the water,
even if we haven’t highlighted that part for
inpainting. We don’t need to say anything,
it will update the whole environment to reflect
the new changes by itself. That is amazing.
Now, I am a light transport researcher by
trade, and this makes me very, very happy.
Thing number two, I don’t know if you caught this,
but this is so fast, it doesn’t
even wait for your full request,
it updates after every single keystroke. Look.
Drawing is an inherently iterative process,
and iterating with this is an absolute
breeze. Not will be a breeze. It is a breeze.
Now, after nearly every Two Minute Papers
episode where we showcase an amazing paper,
I get a question saying something like
“okay, but when do I get to see or use this
in the real world?”. And rightfully so, that
is a good question. The previous GauGAN paper
was published in 2019, and here we are, just
a bit more than 2 years later, and it has been
transferred into a real product. Not only that,
but the resolution has improved a great deal,
about 4 times of what it was before, plus
the new version also supports more materials.
And we are at the point where this
is finally not just a cool tech demo,
but a tool that is useful for real
artists. What a time to be alive!
Now, I noted that earlier, I did not say that
iterating this will be a breeze. But it is a
breeze. Why? Well, great news, because you
can try it right now in two different ways.
One, it is now part of as
desktop application called
NVIDIA Canvas. With this, you can even export the
layers to Photoshop and continue your work there.
This will require a relatively
recent NVIDIA graphics card.
And two, there is a web app too that you
can try right now! The link is available
in the video description, and if
you try it, please scroll down,
and make sure to read the instructions and
watch the tutorial video to not get lost.
And remember, all this tech transfer from
paper to product took place in a matter
of two years. Bravo NVIDIA! The pace of
progress in AI research is absolutely amazing.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!